if you are having a difficult time
booking a copic 19 vaccine appointment
through the health district website
you can imagine you are not alone thanks
for joining us tonight i'm denise valdez
good evening i'm brian loftis as joe
moeller reports the site
is only accepting appointments seven
days in advance
i was having issues too jim ellison says
he was lucky to get his appointment for
monday
just kept trying kept trying and kept
trying and finally got
an appointment time so i must have tried
eight nine ten times after the health
district started allowing people over
the age of 70 to get the vaccine
last week the website to book
appointments was overloaded with people
i thought oh my god we were so lucky
because we just got right on because
then some friends of mine said she goes
i tried all day long
i couldn't get through a window stating
that appointments aren't available until
february pops up
the health district tells us this is an
automated message
you can only book appointments seven
days in advance so more times are being
added
on a regular basis you are encouraged to
check back
all the appointment slots were full and
the site crashed a couple of times it
just took several tries to find an
appointment that was open
cashman center opened friday they expect
to administer thousands of vaccines a
day at that site
after january 18th those in the educator
tier can book appointments according to
the website
everyone getting the vaccine must come
back for a second dosed
that appointment can be made after
january 25th on the southern nevada
health district website
there are a number of other locations as
well monday umc opened a new location at
the encore convention center
those are booked through umc we hope
this is the light at the end of the
tunnel we hope this vaccine works
reporting in las vegas joe mohler 8 news
now the health district also says the
amount of times for appointments could
vary due to the supply of the vaccine
that the health district does receive